guys welcome to this video my name is
grace Helbig is a very exciting day here
on the it's Chris youtube channel
because today we're making corn dogs
this week it's been all about wieners
here on the it's grace youtube channel
and a hot dog inspired makeup look on
Wednesday and today for no other reason
than I haven't done this before we're
making porn and I am is very excited for
not American German they're German are
they sausages I'm using a recipe that I
found on Pinterest
that looks pretty foolproof but I find a
way to ruin things I bought a Hamilton
Beach little desk off deep fryer if
you're ever putting together an officer
yourself invest in a deep fryer watches
vegetable oil I'm going to fill the deep
fryer something sizzling okay it's
getting hot so I'm just gonna pour this
in also definitely don't have enough oil
at all barely filled the bottom
oh we're gonna try it anyway steep then
when life hands you and corndog mix you
make corn dogs so in a large bowl we
have to whisk together ingredients I do
have a whisk so good thing I spent too
much time trying to pick out the right
whisk and not enough time goofily how
much oil I should use for frying
cornmeal flour sugar baking powder and
salt 1/2 cup of yellow cornmeal I also
don't have measuring device tears and
the eyeball at 1/2 a cup that's right Oh
meal on the pants you know that classic
Southern euphemism 1/2 cup of flour
their erotic baking powder I didn't get
aching powder
so I think it'll be okay and as I'm
friend now
salmon alright not have oil right yeah
15 minutes by crying out slivers in 15
minutes and kids is not an ad there's
one company I do know about that
delivers quality content that's
audible.com download your free audio
book on audible comm using the color
autumn calm slash great yes this is an
actual promotion in the middle of this
crisis moment yeah they have vegetable
oil I'm gonna get some more oil at
baking powder beaten leg click play get
me in a measuring cup okay do you want
any other condiments no I'm just not
very good dirt down and we're back with
more oil than ever and I have spent the
last 15 minutes talking about Pokemon go
and try to teach oh my god well it gets
hot real quick in here two teaspoons of
baking powder that was really satisfying
oh just chef bland measuring cup and
measuring spoon set I feel like it's
definitely been opened already glad we
caught these two really two tablespoons
of sugar and if you ever had a corn dog
before what kind of question is that
it's antic flags from my birthday New
Jersey I was broke and I spent all my
money on for nuts I mean that sounds
like any reasonable adult would make
that decision 1/8 teaspoon of salt any
when recipes have those kind of
measurements because like how what do
you figure that out that you should have
a six you should have an eight too much
is it 1/8 of a teaspoon or to get some
teeth but we're done okay
glad you're here okay that's all the dry
ingredients now we're going to mix the
wet ingredients
damn wieners and wet ingredients this
video got sexual okay in a liquid
measuring cup was to go to the egg and
milk one egg can you do the one-handed
to crack
I can try really hard
that was really impressive 1/2 cup of
whole milk oh that was thrilling this is
always the works that they're all fast
so this together and now because this
one's dirty they're all dirty so I'm not
going to take them off this keychain CD
it going to wet ingredients into the dry
ingredients and stir until combined
using a spoon or spatula mothers shirt
we have spoons now we pour and we mix to
be so lumpy my bedroom top this looks
like some sort of skin disease happening
it's fine for now we're time have a
variety of wieners tiny ones I got some
long thin wieners and Oscar Mayer wiener
sent us a care package like a couple
weeks ago just like bags of hot dogs
please don't feel like hot dog this
feels like like a heating pack or
something designer what if there's no
hot dogs actually in here
granite look Oh top top it's hot dogs
yeah let's start skewering these wieners
with sticks
I hope I'm able to get a really sexy
thumbnail of this video which ones do I
go for first
let's do Nathan's first okay a lot of
male names associated with me nerds
right
tell me this is not the dumbest food do
you hold it between your finger your
thumb like that there we go this is the
money shot okay now we're just gonna dip
our weirdness and our slop mix I did not
figure out this whole scenario correctly
so I put this in this basket and then
put it in there time now put the basket
in the fryer first okay should I do two
at a time so I'm very touching the oil
though no okay quickly stop the Wiener
I think opposed to be in there for like
four minutes give me plenty of time to
skewer some other Queens the skewing the
wings hushed XQ that we these are
already gonna break I know it hi
oh is it when I close this and pushes
down oh no they're all going wrong I can
actually go down into there
Oh hot oil the wieners are too big okay
the waiters are too many of the things
everything's fine it's off the
neighborhood delicious golden wieners
I have third-degree burns on my thigh
but I think it's okay let's give some
tiny wings
Oh God
anyways this is wait you do know it's
already cooked
mm-hmm you could eat them cold a broth
you can go round dog and earlier to take
those out of there now oh yeah books is
great looks like an STD s here we go
anyways get in there these are perfect I
truly know what thought with that I mean
these are probably most appropriate for
my struggle monster self because these
ones look like this looks like the hot
dogs themselves are fighting to not be
inside of the cornmeal mixture wow those
look good
right this is cooking check Oscar's
wings keep this one a little loosen to
dip how could I make them look so good
surely hope no one walks by the office
right now Wow oh boy oh boy
get in there is so wet aha beautiful and
something about corndogs is that there's
no place no one is exactly like the
other kosher dill whole pickles have
also very phallic shape which i think
makes them have great potential for some
fried fish lips all the really simple
wouldn't be a wiener video and awesome
dill hulls perfect yeah that looks like
it's gonna be awesome we're back we're
back and we're pumped I'll get some more
pickles go check it out from that excess
oh my god these are my corn dogs you're
gonna see how far we go in one or
I can fry up anything my only concern is
if the post pickle boil instead it's
going to affect the flavor although this
had pickle send it to okay let's put a
bunch of connivance in here condoms of
your meters would be a family-friendly
grid salad video that's given two wings
and putting on some condoms this one
looks like well yeah let's taste that
you want a stash with me I've got I've
got like salad its first oh yeah samples
good salad huh I'm gonna try just as it
is relish all why Bob you just literally
like a hot oil coming out of the pickle
I've never just fit into a pencil before
really oh you're missing out I got
really good though yeah do it but be
like we really have to evaluate your
life these two are the Daniels I start
from the Bob tastes textures to go do
weeks
mmm-hmm doctor look the total got bring
up then we not bad I like this I think
the little ones are gonna be really
awesome Cheers
go all out of the room tough internus of
them mellow funky the crunch that
happens afterwards is an interesting
texture it does mine depicting any age
wonder the prime example don't judge a
book by its cover
unless you're judging Grayson style the
art for Kenny you have it it's a great
cover it's also available in audiobook
format Montcalm's on right I read the
whole book out loud you can download
over free on apple.com such great
now on to these please
I thought himself totally back it
doesn't zip better coating the hotdogs
top snare out for me on this one didn't
get much of it first time around you see
what's happening here
like I said this is a family friendly
meal now we got to go dessert feels like
I've seen you do this so many times
tomorrow and these are s'mores Oreos
who's not regular Oreos and this is
better than regular rosewood tasty fried
are you okay looks like I'm going to cry
guess where you're at right now I don't
think you're here anymore it makes it
worse that there's this like bright
white light like a heaven mohawk to do a
favorite hot dog Nathaniel's really how
to give Oscar Mayer Weiner benefit
except those wieners are sitting in our
office fridge for good bleh deep almost
a month in there oh I don't know time
thank you guys so much for watching this
video if you enjoyed this subscribe and
good luck if you make corn dog it's you
know so easy so easy anyone can do it
I don't know good deal I like to make
food that is attainable not food that
feels perfect or something you couldn't
do on your own
anyone could do this each sorry yeah
sort of your fancy cameras and your
actual cooking skills and you got them
Atmos charisma good hi buddy